大木体をが起きてを見てをつないで寄り添ってはい完成
今日は外れ出場ですツイッターやってるとちょっとしたの follow あたのかで
からすごい情報入ってきました
ってか普通でもツイッターでも話題になってたんですけどもうあたり拭き残してあると
思うんですよあのー例えば
ガリガリくるとかそこボルダー当たり付き残してあると思うんですけどあれって追っ
てるあ
ターンないんですよねこの当たったことが人生この型サブ30回ぐらいしか
結構当たってますねさてに当たるんですけどもその当たりとハズレ月のお菓子があるん
ですけどもそれのあの確実にあたりが当たる方法があるみたいですそれが
twitter で話題になってなんですけどもえっと4つありまして一つは8
10円ガムチョコバットのあたり後チョコボールのあたり酔っちゃいとのあたり
の当て方があるみたいですと出始め始めこれが本当かとがされてくださいよろしくお
願いしますという説があったので食べていきます
これ本当だったら大変ですよ各地で職場と4つんかチョコボールの奪い合いが大きい
日本は大混乱政府は2018年2月から来たこの大反乱をあたり月岡氏の卵とた付けた
謝罪の授業にどれかもしれません
を付けて下さいでもさっそく見ていきましょうまずはチョコバットから見ていきます
これ本当だったら超得な感じでちょこバッドなんですけどもうどこだどこだ
なんかねこれちょっとなんか twitter に乗ってる奴は違うチョコバットだぞ
これ違うぞなんかパッケージそ動画はのくじ付
左腕ギザギザる頂点が粘るもびっくりのフォームナンバージャンドゥ取られてきた画像
にあるチョコバットはなんかこうやバット持ってる少年ネットですって僕買ったらもう
こりごり回野手がボールをベースに会社でなんですけど
じゃあ無理じゃんってま
女じゃんぶりじゃん
逆にこれ自分に発見すればいいんじゃないかなちょっとこの外野手バージョンのチョコ
バットの当たりくじを調べましょう
パッケージそのあたり食ってばっかり何かがあるんだったらそれを逆に俺が探せばいっ
てことでしょ
ほぶわーっ本音
ボジョレー
はずねはい外れたグレーはっはっはっパズル外れあたりないじゃん発でまさかもうさぁ
地図見てこれさぁ地図みたいでさ
1ライフ0000
えっ oro やっぱちゃん14本買って1本しかなかったくせに
ホームランが出たら一番いいんですけどストックしかけませんですっ
ただこれによってこのアタリとハズレが待ってたんでパッケージ何かその違いが
ちょっと見ていきましょうこっちがやっぱりこっちが外れです開け方がきた
が過ぎた申し訳ないんですけどでも細かいところなんですよね twitter に
乗ってたらもうすごい細かったんで
[音楽]
かんねーなー指のホーム数も一緒でしょう二重眉毛の角度も一緒やダメだなまったく
一緒です
無理そうそうもうアタリすらも行けませんでしたっていう感じでした
人目次はこちらは4つ aika ですよっちゃイカポイントは賞味期限
そび勤務地が薄かったらハズレを買ったら当たりみたいですなるほどなぁあーらがある
待ってよん
これ当たり付きかな見たんですよどこにもなく当たり付きの要素はないんですよ
2人月4つ愛が足りてどうなっているだろうかまずはか
ま坂ベックカットよっちゃんにはあたりがついてないってコトメ
big だと言っちゃいてにあったりって概念がないですねビッグじゃないほうの2を
4つは一家にしか食べないみたいですだけじゃねーぞただ普通にょちゃんいなかった
だけになっちゃった
っていうかもうコンビニ普通のゆちゃんが売ってなかったからもうそもそも俺はこれも
無理なってことだったんですちっや最後ちょっとボールいきますやっぱりこのままだと
何も得られない攻めであったりだけでも当てたい8チョコボールはですねわーこれは
また難しいですねキョロちゃんのいると思うんですけどもきょうちゃんの口ば強いが
綺麗だったあたりでのイロハ日れたり知ったら外れみたいですなるほどちょっとか並べ
てみましょう
ほうほうなるほどなるほどなるほど
いやどれも綺麗なんだけどめっちゃ細いんだのもっと近くで見ないとわかんない靴ば
じゃないのがなんか赤い部分にはみ出てたら外れね限りせてなかったらあたりなんです
けど全部はみ出てない
っていうこと全部当たりってことそれがもうパッケージで構成されて新しくなっちゃっ
てそういうなんかあたり言えば分かりやすいみたいなのがなくなっている可能性もあり
ますパッと見ても同じなんですよ
はみ出てる奴自体がもいないんですよか水口の集中にいる塗ってる
多分パッケージで構成されてますねこれはって事はもうまた
順で発見するし金全部開けていきますまであった指付 working
エンジェルが入ってないかテレビは何も外れないんだよパズ
一恵とずれかズレバー王様へ
どうやってそのままだと俺は一体
何やってるんだろう
[音楽]
me
ええええええ
バッハ